[Musik]
also meine damen geschenken jetzt diese
blumen und sie heben wir dafür einen
impfstoff der mit dem gleichen
buchstaben anfängt da setzten sie gerne
dann gehe ich mal rüber zum dorf tun sie
das vollidiot also die leute nerven
gerade wahrscheinlich ganz schön ja die
haben alle alle jeder begegnung werden
das e-mail-postfach läuft über und
telefon ständig still wie könnte ich
denn in eine risikogruppe gelangen
nahezu unmöglich außer man nimmt zu wie
viel muss ich zu nehmen 112 kilo
bräuchten sie schon wie viel big macs
müsste ich essen damit ich in zwei
wochen 22 kilo zunehmen
viel wenn ich nur seine trinke auch viel
aber es gibt leute die sich vordringen
wollen das ist ein fakt das gibt es ja
das ist natürlich unter aller kanone
das geht überhaupt nicht da habe ich
tatsächlich noch nie vergessen und echt
noch nie einen champagner bekomme ich
ganz böses so trennen
und vielleicht ist jetzt doch der
zeitpunkt kommen wo wir uns doch nicht
mehr weiter unterhalten 1 bleiben sie
erst mal locker noch glock haben und
noch locker noch etwas aus der tasche
gefallen das kann gar nicht sein weil
ich habe nie bargeld bei mir habe herr
doktor kollegen ja ok hallo
sie seien auch ärzte hier nein ich habe
gerade mit dem herrn dr gesprochen und
der marke sie sollen wir mal den raum
zeigen wo die impfdosen
das ist sehr sehr ungewöhnlich
das habe ich auch gedacht ich kann ihnen
vielleicht verzeigen wo das wartezimmer
das wasser
[Musik]
zunehmend ist doch schon
ich wollte euch nur um ein kleines auto
bieten
einfach anklicken macht's gut
los los du scheiße fährt